[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN NILSON: Good
morning, everyone,
and welcome to Google I/O 2019.
It's great to be
back on this stage
again, here with all of you.
And we're really excited
to tell all of you
about what's new in
the Google Cast SDK.
My name is Kevin, and I'm
the Global Head of Technical
Solutions Engineering at Nest.
JUNG-YU (GINA)
YEH: Hi, everyone.
My name is Gina.
I'm a Google Casting
Lead for Google Nest.
My team and I support
external developers
to build amazing cars apps.
KEVIN NILSON: So before we begin
talking about the things that
are new in Google Cast, I
want to give you a reminder
and an overview of
where Cast began.
So Google Cast began
over five years ago
for the Chromecast device.
And the way things worked was
you'd be looking at your phone,
playing a piece of media,
watching that media.
You look up, see a TV,
or see a large speaker
with a TV with a Chromecast,
or a speaker with a Chromecast
audio.
Say, wow, I'd like to play
my content on that device.
Then you look down at your
phone, see the Cast icon.
Press the Cast icon, and
magically cast that media up
into your TV or large speaker.
And this gives a
great experience
for the users where
they could expand--
or cast-- what they
have at their phone
up into their large displays
in their living room.
This gave a really great
experience for everyone,
was very, very simple,
and a lot of the things
we're going to talk about
grow on top of that.
Cast has grown from the
traditional Chromecast.
The same code that you'll
write works on the Google Home
devices, the smart
display devices,
and continues to work on mobile.
One of the nice things
is the Google Assistant
can also be used to tie it
all together using your voice,
making your voice a cinder
in the Cast ecosystem.
For those of you developers,
Cast is a great platform
because this code that
you'll write one time
can be used on all of
these different platforms
in our ecosystem.
And so you write that
code once, and it
runs on all these devices.
Cast is a unique
technology that's actually
based on Chromium, and
so the Cast receiver
that's running in the
Chromecast or in the Google Home
is actually chromium,
and it's a chrome base.
And so for all the web
developers out there,
this is a very, very convenient,
very simple-to-understand
platform for developing
your applications.
Videos are played in
an HTML5 video tag,
and audio tag, CSS
and HTML are used
for your theming and styling
within your application.
JUNG-YU (GINA) YEH:
Last year, Chromecast
celebrated its fifth birthday.
Huge congratulations to
everyone who's working on
Cast with us
throughout that time.
Over the past five
years, Cast Playback
has been continuously
growing, and we have seen
a 40% of year-over-year growth.
Before we jump into
the new features, let's
quickly go through some commonly
used Cast terminologies.
Google Cast is the technology.
Chromecast, Google
Home, Google Nest Hub
are devices that use
Google Cast technology.
A sender app is an app running
on your mobile app running
on your mobile phone or laptop
that connects to a Google Cast
device.
And your voice can be used as a
sender to control the playback.
A receiver is an HTML
application running
on a Google Cast device.
Lastly, casting is the
act of streaming of media
on a Google Cast device.
KEVIN NILSON: Now, I want
to talk about our newest
framework called CAF, and it's
the Cast application framework.
But before I do that,
I want to step back
in history a little bit.
And six years ago, when we first
built an SDK for Chromecast,
for Google Cast, and Chromecast,
when we built that SDK,
we wanted to build something
that was extremely flexible
and would let you build
any type of application,
be it something for streaming
media such as video or audio,
or be it a game, or
building dashboards.
And this works
really great, and it
allowed developers to
experiment and build
a lot of great things.
But one of the things
that we noticed
was that it was extremely hard
to build a media application.
And so what we did
a few years ago
is we went out and built
the Cast application
framework, which had the
goals of, rather than being
a library, it could be used
like we previously had,
making a framework
that was fully
designed with the intention of
making it easy to build a media
application.
And that framework
handles all the UI
about playing and
pausing, all the commands.
It provides support for
things like voice control
with a Google Assistant out of
the box with 0 lines of code
additional.
And so what I want
to do is tell you
some of the key fundamentals
of CAF before we jump into it.
When we went out
to build CAF, we
wanted to build something
that was very simple,
very, very simple for people
in building media applications
while at the same
time not giving up
on any of the flexibility.
We wanted you not to have to
write very many lines of code.
We wanted default
implementations
that provided the behaviors
that you need within a media
application.
While at the same
time, we wanted
you to be able to style and
theme that application so
it feels like your own.
And one of our main goals
was is that almost all
of the code you write
is logic code that's
specific to your application,
things like handling
authorization, authentication,
making these decisions,
you know, has your user paid for
their account, does your user
have access to play
this particular content?
Rather than dealing with things
like seeking and scrubbing
within the videos, or
pausing, or showing metadata
about what's
currently playing, we
wanted to make all
that available for you
with zero lines of code.
So, before we jump
into the what's new,
I want to give you an overview
of how to write a very, very
simple CAF receiver because
we know that many of you
have already migrated your
Android and iOS apps to CAF.
But, today, a lot of the
last remaining features
that are needed for a CAF
receiver we've actually
launched a week ago.
And so we know that
many of you are still
in the process of migrating
to the CAF receiver.
That's why I want to
give a quick overview.
The first thing
you'll do is you'll
add a custom element of
the Cast media player.
The Cast media
player custom element
is really where
all the magic is.
This brings in all the UI
around the media playback
and gives a very rich
media experiments.
This expands out
with a shadow Dom
to contain all the
different metadata, all
the different states,
the ability for touch
support in the smart
display devices.
All of that comes with
just this one tag.
The next thing you'll
do is add a script,
adding the Cast
receiver framework
into your application.
And then finally, two lines
of code that you need to do
is get an instance of
the Cast receiver context
and then call start.
This is really all
you need to do.
But for many of you, one of
the things that's common to do
is when you play a piece
of media or stream a piece
of media to Cast
on a Cast receiver,
you'll often pass across
some sort of identifier
for that piece of media and then
later add additional metadata.
And so here in this
example, I'm demonstrating
how you can use a message
interceptor within your load
request and the
load is the play.
And so when a sender, be it
an Android device, an iPhone,
possibly your voice, when a
sender sends across that load
request, they'll
often pass an entity.
And the entity is a
universal deep link
that tells what is the content
that you would like to play.
But it doesn't include
additional things
such as the cover
art or the thumbnail,
the duration, maybe the
type of content that it is--
is it an audio content,
is it video content?
And so often what will happen
is you'll load a piece of media
with an entity that's a
universal deep link as you
see here.
And then in this example, I'm
making an API call into an API
that I have around fetching
the additional metadata
about that asset and
authorizing the user.
Once I get that call
back here in the promise,
we'll go ahead and fill
in the content URL.
That's URL that
can be used to play
the piece of media and then
the additional metadata
around to support it.
So it's very, very simple.
And you can see the
code that we have here.
This is your custom logic.
This is logic that's
specific to your application,
while, at the same
time, you're not
having to deal with the
Dom putting elements
like the icons on the
screen or the loading.
All of that is handled
out of the box for you
with the Cast
application framework.
One of the really
exciting features
that we're launching
here earlier last week
is support, better support
for both live and ads.
And for ads, as
you can see here,
we give a great experience
across senders and receivers
as well as our touch display,
smart display devices.
And you can see here where you
get a great experience for ads,
but it's actually very, very
simple for the developer.
And Gina is going to walk
through that in detail
in a little bit.
But what I can
tell you before she
jumps into that is
all you're doing
is providing a little
bit of metadata.
You provide a little
bit of metadata
about where your ads are and
you get this UI treatment
across all the senders
and the receivers
so you get a really nice
experience for your users.
Now let's take a look
at the mobile apps
and some of the things that we
provide with the CAF framework.
First, we have an indicator
letting the user know
when an ad is being played.
We allow you to
provide a poster image.
And so here you can
see the Nest Hub
where you have an
advertisement for the Nest Hub.
At the same time, if
you have skippable ads,
that can be done by just
giving us the metadata,
telling us whether or
not the ad is skippable.
And then finally,
you'll have ad markers
that you see on the bottom of
the scrubber bar in yellow.
And so those ad
markers only show up
if the ad hasn't
been shown before.
Next, I want to
talk about the UI
that you get on a Chromecast,
on the cast receiver.
Again, you can see
that ad marker.
And then letting you know
that this particular ad is now
skippable from your
device, from your phone.
And then finally, the Google
Home Hub has all the same UI
treatment around ads.
You get a really
nice experience.
But then it becomes a button,
so you can click that button
to skip the ads.
And we know that many
of you haven't yet
started using skippable ads.
But we believe soon all
of our media partners
will start to explore
this and use this feature
to drive additional ads
revenue and make a better
experience for your users.
And CAF is ready.
So Gina, why don't you tell
everyone how they can do it.
JUNG-YU (GINA) YEH: Yeah, sure.
Now let me show you
the ads metadata,
a break clip is a video that we
want to show [INAUDIBLE] ads.
And developers can
assign a content URL
to your video with
a poster image
and values for
skippable ads, values
are assigned to whenSkippable.
And the SDK will show
that the SDK will displace
the [INAUDIBLE] timer and the
[INAUDIBLE] based on the value
that your provided.
A break refers to an interval
of the playback, which includes
one or more break clips.
And positions must be
defined to indicate
when the ads should start.
In the previous
slide, we have talked
about break clip and break,
which are the ads metadata.
And now let me show
you how to insert
your ads with your content.
Starting from initializing
the Cast receiver context,
get a player manager.
With the player
manager, you may want
to implement the load
message interceptor
because typically a load
requires a [INAUDIBLE]
without any ads.
So, inside the
interceptor, [INAUDIBLE]
the break clips and breaks
at the media object.
Google Cast SDK supports
the industry standard.
VAST and VMAP, which address the
compatibility issues for ads.
For VAST, update a break Clip
object was a VAST, with a VAST
ad URL and the SDK
parses the XML feed
and populate over the main data.
VMAP operates the same as VAST.
As Kevin mentioned, it's easy
and simple to use our API
to provide a little
bit of XML data
and the SDK handles the
UIs across the services.
On CAF, cast
application framework,
the SDK not only
handles the UI for you,
but also provide a smart
default behavior when users
seek past multiple breaks.
For example, when a user
seek past two breaks,
the SDK plays the last
unwatched break, in this case,
break three, before
the content begins.
This is the default behavior
provided by the SDK.
It's easy to customize
what we have here as well.
Get a breakManager
from a playerManager
and then use state
breakSeekInterceptor,
which returns a breakSeekdata.
That is an array
of breaks betraying
seek from and seek to.
So developers can choose
which ads shall be played
before the content begins.
Developers can also
update the ads metadata
before it is loaded.
By using the
setBreakClipLoadInterceptor,
update the contentURL
to anotherGreatAd.
We have gone through
the most important part
of ads in the Google CAS SDK.
For more information, check
out the developer guides
at developers.google.com/cast.
KEVIN NILSON: Now
I want to tell you
a little bit about
our new live feature.
We're really excited
about the support
we've added for
Live, because we know
that there are many
great apps out there
today with support for Live.
But one of the
things that we know,
is this takes several
thousand lines of code for you
to do traditionally.
This was very, very
difficult. A lot of code
had to be added in the
senders and the receiver
across the app.
And one of the things that's
really, really unique about
the way that streaming media
servers work for live streams,
is often streams are not
refreshed for 24 hours.
And sometimes it's as
much as every two weeks.
And so one of the things
that we support in Live
is this ability to take your
scrubber bar, your progress
bar, and zoom it into
the individual program.
And so if you think about
traditional linear TV,
typically you have
30 minute episodes.
Here we have "The
Big Bang Theory."
And this episode starts
at 8:00 and ends at 8:30.
Even though the manifest goes
on much, much longer in the past
and in the future,
here you can see
we've zoomed into the
individual program.
One of the other great
features that we add
is the support for DVR window.
And so, if your content
has a DVR window,
here you can see where we give
you the ability to scrub back
in that DVR window.
But if you have something
like a sliding window DVR,
we will constantly move
that DVR window for you.
We have support as
well for the concepts
like giving the ability to
scrub from the position where
the person began playback.
Or streams that are only
live, that don't support
any scrubbing whatsoever.
So all of these are provided.
It's very, very simple
with just adding
a little bit of metadata.
Gina's going to walk you
through some of those details
here in a minute.
Now we'll look at mobile
and the experience
that we have for Live.
You can see at the
top, we've changed
to show the current episode.
And so traditionally,
support for programs
themselves is now
part of CAF, so
that rather than showing
the entire stream,
we're able to change
that title from program
to program for
you automatically.
We also show the duration
how long the program is, so
that your users know.
And then we have an
indicator for Live,
letting them know if they
are at the live point or not.
And that's often a very, very
useful thing for the users
to know.
And then finally,
showing the progress
within that DVR window.
Where you're at and how
far back you can scrub.
On the Chromecast, we've
also done similar treatment
where we have support for
all the various metadata
that you have on the senders.
So here you can see the
live point, the scrubber,
the progress, where
you're at in playback
and where everything is.
As well as like we've always
had, the play and pause.
And remember that,
if you look at this,
you'll see that the TV is
currently in a pause state.
So we have a pause icon.
Now I'd like to show
you the Google Home Hub.
And before I jump into
talking through some
of the things we
have for Live, I
want to point out
that on the Home Hub,
we're actually showing a play
icon rather than a pause.
That is because this
is a clickable button.
Where on the TV, on the
lean back experience,
we're showing a pause,
because that is the state.
Where on the Google Home Hub,
we're showing a play button,
because that is clickable item.
So there's a lot of great things
you can support here with Live.
Show all the various metadata,
it's very, very simple.
And Gina will show you
sort of just like ads,
just giving us the metadata
is all that you need to do.
There's no real
code, it's mostly
just metadata that makes
all of this possible.
JUNG-YU GINA YEH: OK,
now let me show you
how to insure the
program guides for a law
around the livestream.
Get a queueManager
from a Playermanager,
and then in the load
messager interceptor
specify the string type as live
and set content or metadata.
A container metadata can be
used as a TV channel which
holds the title of the channel
image and programs as sections.
Let's take a look at how
a section looked like.
A section is a TV
program and that's
called a first one
is current show
and the second one is next show.
In this sample, the
current show's title
is "The Big Bang Theory."
And z section
start absolute time
is the start time
of the TV show.
Define the section
duration as the duration
of the TV show which is
30 minutes in this case.
Developers can provide as many
shows as you can with our API.
As Kevin mentioned, it's easy
and simple to use our API
to provide a little
bit of live metadata.
And SDK handles the UI's
across all the services.
It automatically
updates the title
as on the program guides
provided by the developers.
Live has been launch in alpha,
and we are adding more support
as I speak.
For more information, check
out the developer guides
at developers.google.com/cast.
KEVIN NILSON: Now I
want to go and talk
to you about our new smart
displays and the support
that we're adding
for smart displays.
And, as you can see here, smart
displays have touch support
and so you can touch.
And I'm going to talk to
you both about customizing
the buttons as well as the media
browse where you're browsing
across different content
that you're able to suggest
and control for your users.
And one of the things that's
really nice about this
is this content is only content
within your application.
And so it keeps the user in
your app continuing to watch
and continuing to grow the
session watch time and session
length.
So let's go through
how to add the buttons
and customize the buttons
on the smart display
devices such as the Hub.
So we're going to
start by giving
an instance of the controls,
that's your buttons,
and then we're going to
create a player data binder.
And with that
player data binder,
we're going to add an event
listener for media changing,
because we know a lot of times
when a piece of media changes,
you're going to want to
change those suggestions to be
something that's relevant to
the currently playing item.
From there, the first thing
that you're going to do
is clear out the
default buttons.
And one of the
things we do in CAF
is, like I mentioned earlier,
we provide an out of the box
default experience
that hopefully gives
the user a great experience.
But we know that sometimes you
may wish to change the buttons,
add or remove various
buttons, and provide
a better experience
for your users
in your particular scenario.
And so, back to this, once
you've cleared those default
buttons, we're going to go
ahead and assign new buttons.
And you can see here, I'm
assigning into the primary slot
number one a seat
backwards by 30 seconds.
And so if you look at the little
diagram on the bottom right,
you can see in the blue,
those are the primary buttons.
And those will tend to hug
around the play/pause button
in the center.
And then we have secondary
buttons, that in this example,
are on the outside.
So putting the secondary
one on the left
and the secondary
two on the right.
We will also, in the near
future, be, in some scenarios,
moving the secondary
buttons onto the right.
And so that both secondary
buttons will be on the right,
while other times, they'll
be on the two sides.
And so that's why we have
primary and secondary buttons
within the application.
One thing that I do want
to remind folks about
is call out the
player data binder.
So if you look at this
example, you may say, "Well,
why can't we do this as part of
the load, when a piece of media
is loading?"
What we would like you to do
is use the player data binder
for dealing with any
UI element changes
that need to happen
within your app,
so that you can structure
the UI elements differently
than actually loading
the media itself.
The other main
advantage to doing this
is when you're on a
remote control device.
So imagine you have one of
the smart display devices,
but you're actually casting to
a Chromecast in your living room
TV, but then browsing content
on the smart display device.
And so that the smart display
device itself is actually not
playing the content at all.
And so, in that scenario there
isn't a load request at all.
And so, by using the
player data binder
you're actually able
to have those controls
and manipulate on both
the Chromecast that's
playing the content, as well
as the smart display devices.
And some of the
instances where people
will change this
is a lot of people
have mixed types
of content where
some of its premium,
some of it's non-premium,
and they may change the buttons.
Or people may have a mixture of
both video and audio content,
as well as things like
podcast that have a little bit
different treatment.
Now I want to show how to
implement the media browse.
And the media browse
is when you're
watching a piece of content
on that smart display,
you click on the screen,
and it will bring up,
you can pull up from the
bottom some suggested content
that you would like your
users to be able to play.
And so, here in
this example, we've
added an item, a "Star
Trek Discovery" item.
And you can see the various
metadata, the subtitle
and the duration for that.
You're able to specify exactly
what image you would like
to use and then the entity,
that universal deep link,
into this piece of content.
Finally down on the
bottom, again, we're
going to listen to that
media changed event,
and every time media
changes I'm going
to update what
information I would
like to show in media browse.
And so what I'm going to
do is within the controls
we used before, I'm going
to set the browse content
and pass in these items.
You'll notice below there
in green at the bottom,
I'm calling this latest
episodes and so for CBS
they like to highlight the new
shows that come out every week,
and let you see
what those shows are
because they believe that's
what's best for the users.
Other applications may
want to put something
different in that
shelf, such as they may,
may wish to say
comedies or sports,
or you may wish to
say continue watching,
or you may want to
call it up next.
You have full control
about what content becomes
available within that shelf.
And all of these great features
are available on the next Hub
Max that all of you heard
about in the Keynote.
And so you write this code.
It will work on their
traditional Hubs as well as
the Hub Max.
Now I want to talk
about a feature
that we call intent to join.
And intent to join is something
that helps bring users back
into your application.
And so you can
imagine, if I come home
and the TV is playing.
Maybe my kids, maybe my wife,
is watching something on the TV.
One of our favorites from
Blender, Tears of Steel.
And I see that content.
And then I look down on my
phone and I have a notification.
And with this notification, if I
click on the notification, what
I want to do is be able to go
directly into my application
and have full control
in the expanded control
so that I can control that
while at the same time
being able to seek
to different content.
And this is intent to join.
And what's different is, if
you don't add support for this,
we don't know how to deep
link into the content,
and so we actually bring the
user into the home app itself.
And so would rather
give you the ability
to bring that user
into your app,
so that they stay with you.
So to add support
for intent to join,
the first thing you're going
to do in your Android manifest
is to add an intent filter.
And within the
intent filter, you'll
define which schema, so
HTTPS in this example,
define the host
like who you are,
which intents you're able
to handle, and then a path.
And so that path is joining the
cast session in this example.
And so, finally, down at
the bottom, and you're
on resume of your
Android activity.
Here we are.
We're going to parse
out that intent.
We're going to get
the data and check
that if it equals the intent
that we are expecting,
then I'm going to
go ahead and start
the session with that intent
and that's what brings you
into that expanded control.
Next I want to talk
about some support
that we've added
into the ExoPlayer.
So ExoPlayer, if
you haven't tried it
for playing media on
Android, specifically
if you're dealing with
DRM content on Android,
the ExoPlayer is a really,
really great player
that we have seen mass
adoption across the industry.
Everyone is really
moving to the ExoPlayer
and so for us on the
Google Cast side,
we wanted to work very, very
closely with the ExoPlayer
to build a plug-in and
their extensions that
makes casting very, very
simple, very natural,
and feel like a natural
extension of both Exo as well
as Cast.
And so we've done
a lot of great work
that you can find out in
open source on GitHub.
And that work is being done on
a dev v2 branch that will soon
be merged into the v2 release.
And so check it out if
you haven't tried it.
It's a really,
really great plug-in.
They've been working,
collaborating with us very,
very closely.
One of the things that we
recently did within the SDK
is try to make senders
and receivers be more
coherent and more consistent.
We wanted the API surfaces to
feel natural across the two
and we wanted to make
it easier for people
sending data from a sender to
be able to talk to the receiver
team and debug issues.
And so one of the things we've
always had on the receiver
is this notion of a
load request data.
And so what we've done is we've
taken that load request, that's
play, and we've made
those same API structure
available on the sender.
And so here you can see we've
got a media load request
data with a builder, you
provide the media information,
and then load that on
your remote media client.
Now I'm going to talk
about some of the things
that we've done for developers.
We've made some
changes for developers
to make that experience
much easier and much better
for developers.
And, before I jump into
some of the new stuff,
I want to talk about
some beta channel
that we have available for
the platform that many of you
may not know about.
One of the things that you
can do if you go to this link,
you can actually
register your device
to get early builds
of our platform.
Because devices like
Chromecast and Google
Home are just like your
Google Chrome browser
where they automatically
update to the latest version.
And this lets you
get that new version
a week or two before the rest
of the public or your users
gets it.
So put your device
in this channel
and then, if you find
any kind of issues,
you have time to fix
them or reach out
to us at Google in case
of problems on our side.
Debugging within
Chromecast and Google Cast
is done with the Chrome
DevTools and these
are the best of breed
DevTools out there
that allow you as
a web developer
to be able to set breakpoints,
inspect, look at memory,
make real time changes, and
they're very, very powerful.
But, unfortunately, when
using the remote DevTools, one
of the issues that often happens
is after a minute or two,
we have leaks within
the tools where
you start to have issues
that are unexpected.
Things start failing that
typically wouldn't fail,
and also realize that
you're working on
often in the case
of a Chromecast,
very, very inexpensive hardware.
And on that very
inexpensive hardware,
having the Debugger attached is
a very, very heavyweight thing
that can cause issues.
And so one of the things that
I do want to remind everyone
is that if you have
the Debugger attached
and you're seeing
issues, make sure
that you're still
seeing those issues even
if the Debugger isn't attached.
And Gina's going to talk
about one of the things
that we're adding in a logger
to make it much simpler for you
to do troubleshooting and
debugging, but without having
to attach the full
Chrome Debugger.
Because we know
that in many cases,
we don't need a full
debugger experience.
Even though this is a great
tool for all of you to use,
it's not always required.
JUNG-YU (GINA) YEH:
Receiver Debug Overlay
is a new feature that
we've built for developers.
And it will be launching soon.
It enables developers to add
logs with your custom tag
and then connect from a
laptop to a Google Cast device
by using our Logging Tool.
From the Logging Tool developers
can enable the Debug Overlay
on the receiver
screen, which displays
all the logs on the screen.
At the same time, the Logging
Tool captures all the messages
and display on the laptop.
So developers can
easily trace the logs
and even save them
for further analysis.
We know a lot of
developers who want
to build automated
cast with Google
Cast on your continuous
integration servers.
This year, we have
built a sample
with utility functions, which
you can use to easily add
[INAUDIBLE] in your cast apps.
Check out our Android sample
at github.com/googlecast.
iOS sample is coming soon.
KEVIN NILSON: So I want to
thank all of you for coming.
We've been very, very
excited to tell you
about the many new features--
live support, support
for ad, better
support for touch in our
smart display devices.
We're looking forward to seeing
all the things that all of you
will go out there and build.
If you want to learn
more about Google Cast go
to developers.google.com/cast.
Check out our great
examples on GitHub.
And then we have a new Google
group for making announcements.
And so, every time we release
something new in the SDK,
you can go and check
out those announcements.
[MUSIC PLAYING]